bonsoir nouveau débat en direct sur tv
fil 78 il concerne le canton de trappes
toujours dans le cadre départemental
2015 bonsoir un jeanine mari vous êtes
candidat divers-gauche conseillère
générale sortante bonsoir jean michel
fourgous ce soir l'union de la droite
vos deux binômes se sont qualifiés pour
le second tour qui va se dérouler être
dimanche on va revoir le tableau des
résultats justement sur ce canton la
liste menée par l'ump l'union de la
droite à 38,33 % suivie de la liste
menée par jeanine marie et alain ajaj 29
88 % derrière on retrouve le duo du
front national 16,21 % et le duo
l'alliance europe écologie front de
gauche 11,07 % la règle pour ce débat
est toujours en la même votre temps de
parole est chronométré je vous
communiquerai régulièrement les
indications pour que vous puissiez
mesurer et qu'on arrive à l'équilibré à
la fin de cette émission qui va durer
une demi-heure et la première question
pour ne pas perdre de temps comment
allez vous mobiliser les électeurs pour
ce scrutin à gauche tout d'abord jeanine
marie vous avez huit points de retard
sur la liste de droite
peut-être un petit peu de réserve avec
eux l alliance europe écologie front de
gauche ça n'est pas forcément suffisant
donc aujourd'hui vous dites quoi aux
électeurs de bouche et aux
abstentionnistes on y viendra
l'abstention a été forte sur ce canton
alors sur l'obtention de bord sur trappe
au premier tour la tension est toujours
très forte quelle que soit l'élection à
la 2e au deuxième tour ils se mobilisent
un petit peu plus sur le report des voix
on peut espérer qu'il y ait un report
des voix des gens qui ont voté
différemment au premier tour parce que
ils ont une colère envers
gouvernement actuel envers leurs
souffrances quotidiennes ils l'expriment
comme ils veulent c'est aussi un choix
que leur offre la démocratie et pourquoi
pas et pourquoi pas après sur la
mobilisation ils sont sur le terrain la
licence moi je suis là mais ils sont sur
les trois villes en train de faire tout
le nécessaire donc voilà il faut
toujours espérer pour rattraper ce
retard y est bien aussi c'est
effectivement le canton de trappes qui
couvre les ville d'elancourt la verrière
et bien évidemment la commune de trappes
jean michel fourgous même question
comment vous allez mobilisez vous êtes
arrivé en tête avec m capitaux à l'issue
du premier tour
si on regarde un peu plus dans le détail
sur la ville de trappes par exemple vous
êtes troisième derrière le front
national
donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il va
falloir aller séduire chercher aussi ces
électeurs là pour l'emporter dimanche
écoutez d'abord je pense qu'il ya un
soutien au projet au delà de l'étiquette
de gauche droite
je crois que sur l'emploi
moi je vous rappelle j'ai créé des
emplois dans ma vie c'est bien de parler
de l'emploi mais c'est de l'emploi en
créant des nouveaux impôts qui vont
détruire l'emploi du voisin si vous
l'essayez des mesures comme ça c'est
rien donc là il s'agit d'avoir des
vraies mesures sur l'emploi avec la
caisse qui je suis vice-président au
développement économique on élabore des
projets on veut on promet rien on va pas
promettre comme nos deux collègues
socialistes d'un million d'emplois
lecteurs mais il en est un exemple sont
derrière nous là dessus on le sens et
c'est là et deuxièmement jeu il ya aussi
bien sûr l'éducation où il ya attrape
notamment une forte attente on va et
d'avouer à venir d'avoir une thématique
savoir pour pour les mobiliser bien sûr
que le modèle éducatif et le modèle
emploi il encourt est fortement attendue
attrapé on l'a senti pendant cette
élection mais je pose cette question par
rapport au front national parce que
nicolas sarkozy qui a encore affirmé
aujourd'hui que qu'il fallait attaquer
le fn brutalement frontalement que
c'était une question de vie ou de mort
vous êtes d'accord
vous n'êtes plus tempérée par ce qu'il
va falloir aussi les séduire sur ce
canton l'a beaucoup de problèmes
particuliers que le front national en
tout cas l encours j'en ai pas il reste
dans des zones où il n'est pas présent
au deuxième tour donc d'arriver devant
votre avis oui oui une amie dans les
farces et attrapes
pour l'instant je gère pas trappe et je
pense que il n'a mais ce qui fait vivre
le front national c'est cessé de mentir
aux français toute la journée c'est de
ces deux de donner des faux chiffres et
coûtait rien que le chiffre qui a été
donnée de radier on arradi près de
cinquante mille chômeurs un mois avant
l'élection pour faire croire qu'on avait
inversé la commission peut pas faire
comme ça agace les gens ça fait monter
le front national ça se voit que de
donner des fausses informations
c'est insupportable dans une démocratie
comme la france il faut il faut faire
passer ce message il faut du parler vrai
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs moi j'ai envie de vous dire
vous avez dit après après l'élection la
gauche en tête avec 41%
madame marie fourgous s'effondre sur
elle en cours qu'est ce que ça veut dire
vous aimerez peut-être pas pourquoi vous
dites que vous y serez perdu des voix
enfin moindre éperdue 1900 voix mais
vous
mais vous parlez des des municipales
c'est pas les mêmes taux de
participation vous c'est pourquoi le
grand oui est-ce que c'est du parler
vrai dire ça aux gens vous êtes sûr
qu'on parlait d'elle quand on leur dit
vous avez fait 41 pour ça vous avez pas
le soutien de deux officiels dogmatique
celle de vous et de vos collègues de
l'autre gauche
pourquoi dire 41% mais se dit je pense
que c'est ça qui fait monter aussi le
fonds a cessé de mentir toujours de
tricher avec les gens ils ne le
supportent cette europe écologie front
de gauche qui appelle tout de même à
battre la droite sur ce canton scénique
appelle pas à adoucir où je n'ai pas le
transfert de voix automatique mari si
vous souhaitez réagir réponse en trois
matches on passera de thématiques ils
ont tous appelé à soutenir le binôme
ajaj marie donc c'est fou manama
c'est ce faux moi je vous en voyez déjà
bu l'équivalent après vous savez les
courriers son interprète pas il appelle
à soutenir le faire mais cela dit c'est
pas très grave mais oui c'est cette
petite délicatesse de vie des français
si on les respectait en leur donnant les
vraies informations et deux pas de la
jouer sur les informations je vous lis
avec beaucoup d'humour vous inquiétez
pas on va passer à présent aux
différentes à présent pour la suite de
ce débat si on peuvent afficher juste
les temps de parole pendant que je
présente les deux thématiques qui vont
suivre
nous parlerons tout d'abord être
d'éducation et puis ensuite de social ce
sont deux des compétences importantes
qui incombent aux conseils
départementaux anciennement conseils
généraux voilà les temps de parole à qui
s'affiche 2 minutes 25 pour vous jean
michel fourgous et une minutes à
quatorze pour vous jeanine mari on va
donc commencer avec vous pour cette
première thématique sur la question de
l'école de l'éducation plus globalement
dans votre projet soutien des structures
contre le décrochage scolaire par
exemple c'est un point important ou
encore c'est un peu plus large c'est la
mise en place d'un pass culture pour les
jeunes aussi du département
ça fait partie des propositions autour
de l'éducation aujourd'hui vous portez
vous laissait alors sur l'éducation
c'est sûr que le collège aujourd'hui le
conseil général aujourd'hui par rapport
au collège assure le fonctionnement
assure l'entretien et la construction
neuve des établissements il a commencé à
installer le numérique dans les écoles
en essayant les tablettes dans certains
établissements mais je
crains que nous ne prenions un peu le
retard et qu'ils devraient pour ça
peut-être investir davantage parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui tout passe par
par la tablette
voilà le sac à dos c'est fini c'est tout
dans la tablette c'est tout à l'écran et
on est obligé de faire avec
donc je sais qu'il a fait des essais
puisque j'ai voté le les tablettes y
compris sur sur trappe
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne bien
donc j'espère j'espère qu'il n investira
d'une façon plus générale sur l'ensemble
des collèges du département
une question tout de même à vous poser
si vous siégez si vous êtes élu vous
serez nécessairement dans la minorité
vous ne serez pas dans la majorité au
sein du conseil départemental c'est
possible malgré tout d'opposer on n'a
rien n'est joué a oui mais on arrive on
arrive on arrive à faire passer des
choses
on arrive à faire passer des messages on
arrive à modifier les curseurs et c'est
ce que j'ai trouvé d'intéressant ce qui
était le respect de la pensée de l'autre
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui est qui
qui m'a m'a plu parce que effectivement
être dans une minorité on va mettre nos
conseils municipaux on n'accorde pas
grand chose on m'a nordique aux
minorités et travailler au niveau du
département ça c'est pas tout à fait
passé comme ça ça m'a valu beaucoup
d'ennuis par ailleurs mais je dois
reconnaître ce qui est j'ai réussi à
faire passer quelques idées mais si je
suis réélu ce une deux heures désespère
pas d'en faire passer l'autre on va dire
la thématique de l'éducation dans une
seule force vous avez entendu jeanine
marie le tout numérique c'est une très
bonne option
ça tombe bien c'est dans leur programme
également ben écoutez je félicite bien
marri de ce ralliement tardif
certes et partiel bon les tablettes
bien sûr je crois que vous êtes en
dessous de 5% ont ni par élève
je rappelle qu'elle est en cours on en
est à 100 % et c'est pas une question
est rattrapé d'une ville qu'à des moyens
bombled ça dont vous voyez c'est
perfectible en tout cas bien sûr que
nous demain
on va se battre pour la généralisation
au même niveau que qu'elle encore que le
que la ville de tram bénéficie du même
modèle scolaire qui est citée en exemple
dans la france entière vous le savez
pour trappe que tout le monde
bien sûr il y eut même droit la qualité
d'éducation également également sur les
tableaux numériques aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus attractive bien sûr les
enfants participent beaucoup plus avec
des tableaux numériques bon et on
regrette que trap est pris ce retard
alors que vous aviez les moyens de le
faire j'y ai même moi je vous ai proposé
un des aides et monsieur malandain votre
chef de file a refusé que je l'aide
on peut le regretter parce que c'est les
enfants dont il s'agissait
c'est la réussite des enfants passent
par leur plaisir d'apprendre ça augmente
le plaisir d'apprendre des enfants et ça
augmente le plaisir d'enseigner des
profs donc c'est magnifique comment
peut-on encore hésiter si je vous dis
que je me balade dans le monde entier
parce que je suis envoyé je suis on aime
on se consulte entre bien sûr plusieurs
pays je peux vous dire c'est un succès
vous pouvez augmenter de 30%
vous pouvez vous attendre on sent les
résultats scolaires des enfants
si bien sûr vous avez l'ensemble de
cette culture de ces outils culte de
cette nouvelle catégorie d'outils
culturel et cette fameuse pédagogie mix
aujourd'hui on apprend on rend les
enfants plus autonomes ils ont plus
confiance en eux ils sont plus créatifs
donc c'est formidable et donc il faut
accélérer madame marie compter sur moi
si je suis bon c'est général d'accélérer
sur votre commune
ce dispositif on retient comme 7
enregistré je serais vous le rappeler je
vous informe quand même je vous informe
que le tableau numérique a été installé
dès 2006 dans l'ensemble des écoles de
la ville et et que les pma rigole pas un
par classe et que les pc et que les pc
et que les pc sont dans toutes les
classes aisées connais pas toutes les
classes mais non non parce que
c'est comme ça on n'a pas forcément les
moyens qu'elle avait le d'elancourt il
voyant financier je dis non non mais
t'as un coup quand même à est à 36 les
toiles événementielles y ait quelques
élèves
oui je ne pense pas que ces mises à nu
et sans un gouvernement plus qu'un autre
si le vôtre avait fait effectivement son
temps puisque 2005 2006 était encore le
vôtre je pense que s'ils l'avaient fait
en son temps effectivement la
modernisation des écoles peut-être
effectivement que toutes les écoles de
france se rééquiper comme les modifie
pas le cas ni un budget de la ville sur
le budget est ce que c'est d'ores et
déjà budgétés c'est dans le projet
global de la droite de l'ump pour le
conseil départemental sur la prochaine
mandature cet équipement numérique
donc je sais que les équipes du conseil
général bien sûr souhaite que
l'équipe d'elancourt bien sûr participe
un projet d'intensification de
modernisation bien sûr est de faire du
département des yvelines
un exemple aussi en france bien sûr de
cette évolution de la pédagogie est ce
que parce que c'est vrai on s'ennuie on
piétine c'est pas un lien jours à
l'école de mal heureusement
et aujourd'hui c'est cette culture de
nouveaux outils ça ça réconcilie
beaucoup d'enfants et notamment des
enfants quelquefois des quartiers comme
on dit souvent oui et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut particulièrement à trappes et
à la verrière de faire cet effort et
c'est bien sûr une des raisons pour
lesquelles bien sûr nous fait rentrer
fort on fait entrer si les examens sur
le veulent bien
bien sûr madame marie en tout cas
concert discours nouveau du conseil
général que vous portez parce que
pendant 7 ans parce qu'on a entendu mais
à quoi servirait de renouveler les
équipes de la marine si les programmes
n'évolue pas encore faut-il que cette
équipe ait les moyens financiers je
crois que savoir que le conseil général
va aller quand même l'air de grandes
difficultés que ses priorités
effectivement va falloir les redéfinir
abbas ibn hamad al omari que en lever
750 millions conseil général avec
gouvernement il n'avait pas annoncé
avant de se faire élire sauf que sur le
sort actuel il a ré effet à l'héritage
et aux libyennes obligé à la tâche voilà
donc à un moment donné je crois que
chacun a sa place
une seconde thématique à présent suivre
la discussion la compétence sociale
compétences importantes pour les
conseils départementaux et qui malgré
tout même si c'est encore en discussion
pour les compétences avec une réforme
complète la loi à notre on en a déjà
longtemps parlé sur cette antenne qui
est en discussion et qui actuellement en
discussion je leur précise on vote
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur des
compétences des conseils départementaux
le social tout de même devrait rester et
c'est important et jeanine mari dans vos
propositions liées à la prise en charge
du vieillissement de la population créer
des places d'hébergement pour les
personnes handicapées en situation de
handicap aussi bonne chose je vous
laisse entamer la discussion et faire
vos propositions dans ce registre là
sociale or moi j'avais participé à un
groupe de travail qui s'était créée
justement pour faire un diagnostic sur
le problème de l'hébergement en général
c'est d'ailleurs l'un l'enfance qui est
confiée au conseil général les personnes
vieillissantes les personnes handicapées
ce groupe de travail avait montré le
diagnostic avait montré qu'il y avait un
déficit important effectivement
dans le milieu de l'hébergement de cette
population là ça s'est arrêté en cours
de route je sais pas pourquoi mais je
crains que nous n'ayons par manque
d'anticipation un gros problème à
l'avenir dans les années qui viennent
déjà on le voit au niveau des handicapés
beaucoup de familles sont en belgique
c'est regrettable parce que le coût
d'une journée belgique ou en france et
est identique mais pourquoi le créer
deux emplois en belgique alors qu'on
pourrait avoir ces mêmes équipements
chez nous et à voir les emplois chez
nous et les familles sont à côté de
leurs de leur personne en manque
d'autonomie
plutôt que d'aller s'installer à la
frontière belge ou en belgique
directement
il ya aussi le problème
des ordonnances juridique où on ne peut
pas le placer les enfants qui en ont
besoin parce que il ya une manque de
place criant et en manque aussi de
l'adaptation des métiers à l'évolution
des comportements des enfants et ça ça a
été bien mis en avant tout le monde est
unanime là dessus pour autant pour
autant il ne se passe rien bon voilà
c'est un peu dommage peut-être que ça
viendra mais pour l'instant je pense que
le manque d'anticipation
quand on connaît le vieillissement de la
population et les caractéristiques qui
se se dessine je pense qu'il faut aller
très vite
jeanne marie vous êtes à peu près six
minutes de temps de parole jean michel
fourgous à cinq minutes en une minute je
vais vous laisser résumer vos
propositions autour du social le temps
passe vite ce débat est très court 26
minutes et puis il ya une toute dernière
partie que vous avez en partenariat avec
la radio sensations vous la découvrirez
dans un instant donc je laisse revenir
sur vos propositions autour du social
vaut aussi l'idée c'est de s'adresser
aux familles aidées à la garde d'enfant
ça aussi c'est son ce qu'on retrouve
pardon dans votre programme oui alors je
joue un peu le gardien je suis né à
montreuil dans les chaînes de montrer
j'ai vu et déjà et les missions les
difficultés du docteur en psychologie
sociale je n'ai pas fait une école de
commerce anne-marie souvent j'entends
des caricatures bon là donc on connaît
voilà on est tous les leçons pour aider
les gens les plus en difficulté est
vraiment recentrer les aides d'ailleurs
sur les gens vraiment en difficulté et
je crois qu'il ya un problème dans ce
pays on envoie des aides souvent à des
gens qui ne les demande pour d'autres
raisons et on éduque trouver des
repreneurs soutient par contre oui oui 2
de bien cibler les aides sur les gens
qui en ont vraiment besoin est là et
donc ça il ya un gros travail à faire
même chose pour le rsa il je crois qu'il
faut vraiment le bien le cibler sur la
reprise d'activité il faut rendre
beaucoup plus actif les dépenses
passives du chemin et je vous rappelle
que quand vous travaillez en plus c'est
moral parce que une entreprise ça donne
50 % de son chiffre d'affaires à la
société à l'état donc c'est moral de
remettre tout le monde au travail et que
tout le monde participe à financer le
système là il faut il faut que tout le
monde mais sur soi bien impliqué dans ce
dispositif d'abord il faut augmenter
bien sûr le nombre d'entreprises la
création d'entreprise la création
d'emplois c'est toute cette machine qui
alimente parce que si vous casser la
croissance comme c'est fait actuellement
1 0 % en 2000
12 0% en 2013 0 pour 0 4 enfin c'est
pareil en 2014
oui vous allez casser on est en train de
casser la production dead et résultats
au conseil général des yvelines
eh bien on vous enlève près de 150
millions sur le social il faudra donc
contre il faut d'abord assurer bien sûr
le financement du modèle social avant de
vendre un modèle social qui est en mis
en faillite parce qu'on s'est pas créé
de la richesse
donc j'étais là il faut bien éligible
interrompt vous êtes en avance sur le
temps de parole d'une quarantaine de
secondes on va s'arrêter là pour cette
série des changes entre les
représentants de ces binômes de l'union
de la droite et représentants des divers
gauche je vous précise aussi que
l'abstention reste le premier parti de
france un manque d'intérêt pour le
scrutin à relativiser à l'échelle
nationale qui reste très important sur
le canton de trappes et qui fera la
différence vous restez donc en plateau
une courte pause micro trottoir pour
savoir si justement vous irez aux urnes
dimanche et s'est ensuite grégory kamel
et de radio sensations et qui viendra
vous posez les dernières questions pour
tous que ces espaces ce moment là il
faut faut vraiment il faut aller voter
non je vois pas j'ai pas eu le temps de
faire la procuration pour le premier
tour mais sinon je regrette de ne pas
avoir été voté donc je vais aller voter
effectivement second tour et c'est
important
non parce que je suis algérien chevaux
françaises nous on a le droit de payer
des impôts on a droit de on a droit de
tout sauf de participer à la vie de la
commune tu vois si je peux voter je vais
voter mais
je suis pas là je vais pas voter chez
certains pourquoi parce que c'est vrai
on a un droit de voter 2 c'est tout un
et puis au moins quand on a le droit de
voter on a le droit de manifester s'ils
n'ont le droit de se taire et c'est un
devoir
donc c'est obligé de voûte est
absolument ne serait ce que pour faire
barrage au front national et chose aussi
bizarre que cela paraisse ici à trappes
on n'a pas de section locale du fn et
pourtant les gens voter fn est les six
dernières minutes de ce débat du second
tour sur le canton de trappes grégory
canal et bonsoir un soir de radio
sensations au max nom en face aux deux
représentants des binômes qualifié pour
le second tour vous avez quelques
questions à leur poser soyez bref dans
vos réponses afin que nous puissions
aborder les deux trois thématiques que
vous avez prévu en effet à wilfrid
bonsoir à vous deux les compétences du
département sont actuellement vous le
savez en discussion au parlement à
l'assemblée
certaines de ses compétences du
département risque d'être transféré au
profit des régions comme les questions
de voirie
jeanine mari ma première question
s'adresse à vous un département des
yvelines sans la compétence des voiries
est ce que ça peut poser problème
notamment sur des dossiers tels que
l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 au
niveau de trappes valdys tous les
financements sont prévus et inscrit par
tous en numéro 1 sont toutes les lignes
budgétaires de l'état donc on peut
espérer que quand même il les rend pas
jusque là que le que les voiries son
transfert à la région je trouve ça un
petit peu dommage parce que
le département même s'il a beaucoup pas
faire parce qu'il a pris de retard
lancer dans le développement des voiries
notamment en transversalité
ce qui pose problème aussi pour les gens
qui travaillent
s'il a pris de retard j'ai l'impression
quand même qu'il en a un petit peu
rattrapé dans ces inscriptions
budgétaires et les projets qui est que
nous avons voté me reste encore à faire
donc ça reste des choses de proximité
arrêtent des choses de proximité autre
compétence jean michel fourgous qui
risque de passer sous l'égide de la
région
c'est le développement économique un
département qui n'a pas la main sur ces
questions économiques ça peut être moins
intéressant il ya toujours une marge non
dans un conseil général avec les
différentes hypothèses de compétences
dire c'est quand même un peu marrant les
messieurs que entre deux tours d'une
élection
le gouvernement n'est toujours pas
défini les compétences de cette élection
c'est quand même c'est quand même bon en
matière des matrices mon nez en est au
top donc le développement économique de
toute façon c'est l'interco c'est un peu
le département qu'on le veuille ou pas
aujourd'hui encore et encore un petit
peu même avec les différents types et
c'est surtout la région et c'est aussi
l'europe
vous savez je je voyais encore récemment
le président de la commission du budget
de l'union européenne donc du parlement
européen pour bien sûr préparer des
projets emploi pour l'est pour pour
toutes nos zones pour trappe pour la
verrière pour il en cours et pourrait
pour et pour en général 5 saint quentin
donc de toutes façons c'est un ensemble
c'est un ensemble europe france région
département alors que ça revienne
précisément à 100% la région où que ça
reste à 20% au département peu importe
parce que il faut que les élus
travaillent ensemble nous en tout cas
moi je voyage et déjà je dirais que
c'est ce que vous estimez je vous donne
juste votre temps de parole
vous êtes à 6 minutes 19 jeanne marie et
jean michel faure vous êtes à plus de 7
minutes presque une minute donc ce sera
plus court sur la dernière réponse pour
l équilibre du temps de parole ce soir à
grégory je vous redonne ma dernière
question s'adresse à vous deux pierre
bédier le président sortant du conseil
général parle de grand chelem pour ces
écuries vu le grand chelem de la droite
ça ressemblerait à quoi
un département des yvelines complètement
à droite est ce que ça pourrait pas être
s'apprête à être un risque pour la
démocratie jeanine mari si oui et non
puisque la démocratie c'est le vote si
les gens votent tout le département et
même pays ou à droite c'est le respect
de la démocratie
après c'est dans l'expression au
quotidien et le portage des voix moi
j'ai bien vu quand même l'éclairage
nouveau que j'apportais
lorsque dans mes interventions sur des
villes comme les l'autre voilà ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été entendu j'ai
l'impression que quelquefois pour
certains c'était une découverte
ça c'est assez regrettable c'est pour ça
parce que pour vous ce qu'il faut que le
canton reste à gauche
o pour que ces gens là soient
représentés avec une autre vision des
choses
jean michel fourgous un département des
yvelines complètement à droite ça
pourrait faciliter les choses non mais
je respecte je respecte le choix de le
souhaitent de la mari mais vous savez
pendant 30 secondes dans toutes les
régions
quasiment toutes les régions étaient à
gauche voilà on ne s'est pas préoccupé
de savoir si vraiment voilà l'équilibré
est respecté
non je crois poussé aujourd'hui on est
dans une telle situation c'est nous
comme une autre on perd on perd
quasiment 20% en trois ans on est on est
au bord de l'asphyxié
il ya des vrais problèmes à régler très
vite il faut que le processus
décisionnel et très vite faut produire
la richesse ou prenez des emplois font
pas de nouvelles recettes fiscales pour
payer tout le système social français
donc voilà aujourd'hui priorité priorité
à un système efficace rapide
jeanine marie vous avez à peu près une
minute de retard vous aurez donc le mot
de la fin sauf sur ce débat parce qu'on
a abordé un petit peu de loi le sujet du
front national il faut quand même la
démocratie a du bon c'est vrai on peut
exprimer les colères comme l'a dit le
monsieur en même temps quand même aussi
faire attention que quelquefois ça peut
amener d'autres choses quand la colère
cette frémaux moment s'expriment en
dehors du moment de la colère a le
premier tour on sait que c'est la colère
le 2e tour puis la colère sont les gens
qui gèrent qui gère les affaires au
quotidien donc
moi je ne m'interroge pas sur le score
du national u du front national je
m'interroge sur ce qui n'a pas été fait
par les uns et par les autres pour
empêcher qui monte
ça c'est le rôle des politiques
nationales et je crois que là on est
passé à côté de quelque chose
il sait aussi la colère des gens merci à
tous les deux vous êtes minutes de temps
de parole merci à grégory pour un radio
sensations j'ai mis mon mari candidat
divers gauche conseillère générale
sortante jean michel fourgous candidat
de l'union de la droite vous
représentiez vos binôme ce soir émission
qui sera rediffusée sur tv fils à 19h30
aujourd'hui demain également à mercredi
8h 30 et 20 heures à voir bien sûr en
replay sur notre site internet prochain
débat il sera consacré au canton de
montigny le bretonneux ce sera jeudi à
très bientôt